oh yeah we have to make a video how's it
going bros my name is Pippa and here is
[ __ ] you had a book called how to speak
emoji and I you know being the genius
I'm like we can make this into a video I
feel like someone else has done this
though so basically the idea is that
we're gonna speak to each other with our
phones sitting next to each other but
only with emojis and we have to guess
what the other person is saying you you
at home you can play along this is the
emoji challenge
okay we're gonna start with insults okay
fine you sir
I see you typing nerd can I turn it are
you ready okay
elephants don't fart now LF friends
don't think yeah is it an elephant yeah
well you know three guesses or more okay
what is it never forget oh yeah right
they don't
oh that's so clever
is there an a but emerging we need a
butt emoji dammit he's my butt yeah oh
my god oh my god what is this trained
space look blood toilet that's my
favorite movie of all time
train scope train look trains does train
tell a when you see a train train spicy
something yeah train spot ding yeah
train spotting that was in Trainspotting
yeah that's so lame again okay all right
it's an insult
you so frightened
I can't smash it yeah you got it growing
it's the key words even bigger grow well
grow some balls Culebra all right what
do we got - don't grow hair I can grow a
beard is that what you're trying to tell
me a moustache you know okay okay who is
this a friend you the first one yes so
you're what is that as an emoji you use
a lot you cowboy I got a text my thing
Rock papers isn't it okay well that was
the emoji challenge forget thank you my
dear for playing this game with me thank
you for coming in this channel and check
out Mencia
you and in heaven that's it for now but
if you like it for you and you're
watching and we will breakfast with our
feet